[Music]
[Music]
don't say don't you say left come on
[Music]
pneumatic
I need a new set of lungs dude you just
ran like 13 miles in 30 minutes guess I
got a late start really you should be
ashamed of yourself should take another
lap did you just take
I assume you just took it well unit you
with 58th pararescue but now I'm working
down at the VA Sam Wilson
Steve Rogers yeah I kind of put that
together must have freaked you out
coming home after the whole defrosted
thing takes some getting used to
it's good to meet you Sam this your bed
right what's that your bed it's too soft
and I was over there I sleep on the
ground use rock for pillows like a
caveman I'm home lying in my bed and
it's like lying on a marshmallow I feel
like I'm gonna sink right to the floor
how long two tours you must miss the
good old days huh Wow things aren't so
bad foods a lot better we used to boil
everything no polios good internet so
helped then reading that a lot trying to
catch up Marvin Gaye 1972 Trouble Man
soundtrack everything you missed jammed
into one out I'll put it on the list
all right Sam duty calls
thanks for the run that's what you want
to call running oh that's how it is oh
okay anytime you want to stop by the VA
make me look awesome in front of the
girl at the front desk just let me know
I'll keep it in mind
[Music]
hey fellas either one you know where the
Smithsonian is I'm here to pick up a
fossil hilarious
are you doing
can't run everywhere
you
you